well joining us now is the government
minister health and social care minister
actually edward arga hello to you
lovely to see you thanks for joining us
this morning now
the delays because of the india variant
as we're being told what caused a spike
in the cases of the india variant
well first of all i'm not going to
preempt what the prime minister might
say
later today um but what we have seen
with this
um with this variety is it's highly
highly infectious when i was
doing the morning round about a month or
so ago we didn't know
whether it was 10 more infectious or 50
and clearly
we now know it's about 40 more
infectious than the alpha variant the um
the so-called kent variant that's what's
driving
the spike and we've gone in a week from
around 12 000 cases of delta variant
to about 42 000 that's a big jump
reflecting
the fact that it's that much more
infectious and it's that that's that's
driving the concern
which the prime minister's obviously
looking at very carefully at the moment
we have ourselves to blame though don't
we we should have closed the borders a
couple of weeks earlier when we did with
bangladesh and pakistan well i think
there's a number of points i'd make
there firstly
kay um the variant that we're talking
about the delta variant
at the time we closed the borders that
was not a variant of concern that
specific variant
second thing is we've always got to
remember the red list versus the amber
list as it were at red list doesn't
actually mean
the borders are closed if you're a
british citizen even when a country's on
the red list you can still come back
into this country
albeit with the hotel managed quarantine
and we do know there's a very large
number of of british citizens who have
very strong links to india so those
people would still have been able to
return so we've got to be a little bit
uh careful about understanding the
difference between what happens on the
ambulance and the red
yeah they would have been able to return
most certainly because they're british
citizens but they would have been
quarantined in a hotel
and they wouldn't have been returning to
their homes in the northwest of england
and other parts of the country
spreading the virus but i did come back
to that point i made earlier that at the
time
we did put india on the on the red list
what a better way of putting it
that was not a variant of concern that
came a little bit later so we acted
before
that was actually on the on the list and
we will see more variants
i suspect going forward what we've got
to do going forward
which we've done is make sure we have a
robust border regime
but more importantly that we get those
vaccinations in people's arms because
that's the way
we beat variants which will appear one
of those variants i say the alpha
variant
um was from kent within our own country
we will see
variants coming from other countries and
indeed possibly within our own countries
the way to beat them
yes is to be tough on board restrictions
but it's to get those vaccinations
can we at least accept that if you had
closed the border
with india 14 days before when you did
with bangladesh and pakistan
we may not have been in this position
well i think that's a hypothetical okay
we're saying
we may not have been we don't know it's
the short answer well we've actually
known the packaging i guess we're doing
i mean the figures were twice as much
um in india as they were in bangladesh i
discussed this a
month or so ago we were talking about it
on sky
i don't think that would have would have
necessarily
stopped the variant coming we will see
variants one of the things we've got to
do with this
virus is get those vaccinations in to
get that protection level
up but then we've got to recognize this
disease may well be endemic
for many years we will have to live with
um
coronavirus covid going forward
vaccinations is the way that we can do
that
but you won't accept even the
possibility that if we close the border
of fortnight earlier we might not have
been in this position well it's a
hypothetical okay it's possible but
there's no way of knowing that and i
believe that we took
swift and decisive action we have some
of the toughest
border regimes in the world when it
comes to uh tackling coronavirus
um and i think we acted swiftly and
decisively when that was put on the list
of variants of concern
why didn't we close the border with
india when we did with bangladesh and
pakistan
because we believed the right thing to
do was when that became a variant of
concern we looked at it we followed the
scientific data
we followed the advice we got and we
closed the borders swiftly
on the base of that advice when the
advice was to do so well the scientific
data
on the 25th of march the 7th of april
said that um
india uh 5.1 percent of cases that were
coming into the united kingdom
from india were positive cases
our own numbers whereas bangladesh was
only 3.7 and yet we put them on the red
list and we did in india
well as i said equally in the past there
are a number of other factors when we
make those decisions or when the
scientific advice comes on the decisions
one of them is um
genomic sequencing can we understand
these rounds india has
okay we are world leading this but india
still has an effective genomic
sequencing
um program that's another factor that
will have been considered but i go back
to that point
which is that this specific variant the
delta variant
was not um on that variance of concern
list until as i recall
after we made the decision so we did
move swiftly okay um
how do we speed up the vaccine rollout
given that that's what we need to do i'm
guessing that's what the prime minister
is going to say later on i'm not asking
you to tell me because i know you won't
uh but how do we speed up the vaccine
really well i think we are going
we are going as fast as we can with that
at the moment we got i think an okay
weekend figures
may vary sometimes week one second dose
is about 275
000 into people's arms yesterday as a by
way of an example
the key for us is to catch up with those
second doses hence
the reduction in the interval from 12 to
8 weeks for the over
50s we've got the supply we know we've
got the supply to be able to do that
and one of the key things i would say is
when you're able when you are eligible
to come forward either for a first dose
or for the second days please do because
we're going to point out where we want
everyone who's eligible to actually come
forward and get those jabs so we've got
a gap of about
10 million 910 million to make up in
terms of difference between first and
second doses
we're really keen to make sure that
everyone gets that second dose
as soon as they are eligible hence the
12 to eight weeks
partly because it's better for everyone
but partly because
we've seen the latest public health
england evidence there'll be more
research done on this with one dose
you are 33 roughly 33 protected
against the delta variant with two doses
that goes up to 81
and that's the key to being able to
safely ease restrictions and at what
point
will we as a nation be comfortable with
this virus we know that the numbers
of people contracting covert 19 the
delta variant
are increasing exponentially but but the
death rate is
um remaining about the same at what
stage do we accept that we
have to live with this virus well as you
heard me say there okay i think we have
to once we've got people vaccinated once
we've got those first and second doses
crucially second doses
into people's arms and once we see that
link
clearly severed between getting the
disease and
hospitalizations and severity of disease
and we're seeing some really positive
news on that
although with the delta we are seeing
the numbers in hospital creeping up a
bit i think there were just over a
thousand
um at the weekend but when you look back
it was something like 38 000 at the peak
in january so we are seeing
that that severing of the link between
the disease um and hospitalizations and
death and i think
that on that basis i think everyone will
will recognize that there comes a point
where we do have to live with this
disease
and recognize that it's you cannot go
for a zero covid
approach you have to live with it and
vaccination is the key to that so i
think once we've got those second doses
in people's arms once we've got that
level of protection up to around eight
that 81
then i think people will be more
comfortable with it and we can see uh
we can see more easily and if we extend
lockdown we'll be extending the follow
scheme
well i know that um and and quite
rightly you haven't tempted me to
speculate on what the prime minister
will say later but i know that when he
addresses his decisions sets out what he
uh intends to do around the easing on
the 21st he will address those points as
well
that could that they are the table there
are things he is i think he is very
mindful
of the need for businesses and others to
get the support they need if they uh
continue to be locked down or unable to
open but i don't want to preempt what
he'll say but i know he's very sensitive
to those
days in fact that's potentially still on
the table what about weddings 50
000 couples if we if we delay for a
month theoretically
50 000 couples will have to take that
big red pen to their list
again they've we're chatting to a guy
later he's had to cancel his wedding
three times
postponed his weddings three times so
far um absolute torture is how he
describes it
what concessions might there be for them
well you're absolutely writing the key
word there was you said again there will
be a lot of couples who've
planned hope to do it put a line through
it done it again and resell it again
not only does that cost money but
emotionally that's incredibly difficult
for for couples who want to have their
special day and want to get married
again i'm not going to preempt what the
prime minister will say
later but i know that weddings and
people in that
particular situation will be very much
um in his mind at the moment and it's
one of the things he's been looking at
because he's just got married himself so
he realizes the challenges of the big
day
um so that is something that he's
looking it will be something in the
context of
what his announcement is later that will
be one of the things i know that he will
be giving
very careful consideration to you're
teasing us you're enticing us with what
he might be saying later on it's a good
build up to
um hearing from the prime minister will
mps get to vote on the restrictions
yeah my understanding is yes we've been
very clear that um
where there's a substantive change
whatever that may be
i mean obviously if he's easing them um
then the road map continues as normal if
he does announce a delay
then of course we're clear where there's
a change to that roadmap were he to do
so
parliament would have to say okay do we
have enough stock
of a vaccine in the united kingdom at
the moment to reduce
the uh gap between first and second
doses to say eight weeks
we're confident so the advice reducing
for the over fifties for example from
twelve weeks are you pointing
to eight weeks no no i'm not did you
see that i would not do that i would not
have dreamt of doing that okay but no
12 to eight weeks um we are confident
that we can do that it's the right thing
to do it's safe
um but that also we've got supplies to
deliver on that commitment so we do so
we are confident that we can deliver on
that
and that we will get those um stick to
that key commitment which is the
by the end of july adults having it all
adults have you had both of yours yet
um i've had my first one okay which
shows i'm a little bit later i'm
i'm not quite over 50 yet okay we're
going to move on from age and
if you mention it again you're not
coming back talk to me about northern
ireland
what on earth is going on uh we've heard
uh that the french didn't feel that
northern ireland was part of the united
kingdom that's what the foreign
secretary said the french said don't be
ridiculous
we of course accept that it's part of
the sovereign nation of the united
kingdom and northern ireland
um it's not going to go away this issue
no i mean i hope that
president macron misspoke when he said
that
and i hope that it's not reflective of
perhaps an attitude in brussels or a
view of
northern ireland quite clearly it is as
you say an integral part of the united
kingdom
northern ireland protocol is in place it
is challenging
at times but we've got to do everything
we can which is exactly what we're doing
to make sure that we honor obligations
north-south but also east-west and the
prime minister's been very clear
that making sure that northern ireland
gets the supplies it needs continues to
have
be treated as an equal in the united
kingdom is of paramount importance to
him
i hope that in the discussions which we
saw last week and continue to have with
the european commission we've set out
what we think
is needed to make it work i hope that
they will respond
in kind with a comprehensive and
pragmatic
offer and in those discussions but the
prime minister's been very clear
that regardless of that he will do what
is necessary to make sure northern
ireland
continues to be treated fairly as an
equal part of the united kingdom a lot
of criticism from
former prime minister gordon bryan he's
very critical of the way boris johnson
is treating
northern ireland talking i mean it was a
dire warning he said
the future of the union is at stake
unless the needs of all four nations
are nurtured um northern ireland
certainly feels like a poor relation at
the moment if what our reporters out and
about
are getting that impression will we
extend
the period past the 30th of june if
necessary
in order to try to get a deal over the
life well as i say i'm hopeful that
we'll make progress and that
the european commission will be
pragmatic in its response but the prime
minister's
been very clear that all options remain
on the table
to make sure that northern ireland
continues to be treated quite rightly
as an integral part of our united
kingdom and he says all options remain
on the table to make sure we do that
that's the 30th of june
well at the moment i'm waiting to see my
perspective from medicine's perspective
i'm waiting to see what the european
commission comes back with we've told
them what we need we've told them
address the issues i hope that they will
come back in the coming days with a
comprehensive
and pragmatic response but the prime
minister's being clear the integrity of
the united kingdom is of paramount
importance and an answer to my question
well the answer to your question is
let's wait and see what brussels comes
back with
not a waste isn't there today i'm afraid
yeah we'll hear from the prime minister
later on for now thank you very much
thank you for joining us